he is Peter King here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Peter everything's good
rich how are you I'm great so let's get
jump right into it here how did the
Cutler stuff come together basically
best you can tell you know after Ryan
Tannehill got hurt on Thursday at
practice you know they didn't know how
serious it was at first but not long
after that Adam GaSe called Jay Cutler
and basically said do you have interest
me says yeah I have interest but I want
to think about it
obviously and then he thought about it
I'm told for 48 hours he was serious
about doing this TV and he thought that
it was a good transition to his next
career but there's probably one guy who
who if he makes that phone call Jay
Cutler is very very likely to say yes to
and that's Adam GaSe in 2015
obviously Adam GaSe coaching the
offensive coordinator for Chicago Jay
Cutler played very disciplined football
had all things considered his best
season for the high rating only 11
interceptions and I think that he
basically decided especially after the
money was fairly right 10 million and 3
million in pretty makable incentives
Cutler said I've got to do this because
I'll always wonder what it would have
been if I didn't do it yeah you know I
mean Tony Romo with Romo that being the
NBA game analyst next to an all-world
person and talent like Jim Nantz that
that's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
they'll always be a three-man booth at
Fox that they want to put them in I
imagine so so that that that's one thing
but the relationship with gates what why
do you think these two guys get along in
a way that Cutler and other coaches
supposedly have not I think in part
because Adam GaSe you know basically
having been around a lot of good
quarterbacks
in his life
Adam GaSe is kind of you wouldn't know
it by just looking at him on television
but he's commanding presence and he
demands from his players you know that
you'd do it absolutely the right way and
I think when he went into Chicago that's
what he demanded and if you ask Mike
Shanahan Jay Cutler is is fine with
being coached he likes being coached and
I think that was the big thing here that
Cutler was coached to be a very
disciplined uh you know quarterback
making the right reads and I think it we
felt that Cutler felt he was a very good
fit with gays well Peter King joining me
here in the Honda inside report now
comes the fact that they play in the New
England Patriots division how does this
work football wise do you think Peter
well I mean Cutler if Cutler goes on to
against the Patriots and has one
touchdown and five interceptions in the
two games quite honestly and his signing
by the dolphins and all likely it will
be a failure IRAs tenure there will be a
failure and you've got to find a way to
play look I I think everybody who looks
at this on the surface thinks that
basically with the receivers that Miami
has it's going to be bombs away football
but I can tell you this the way that the
way that that Adam GaSe wants to call
the game has more to do with jje than it
does with the three receivers combined
you realize it last year when gates
called 50 percent runs or more in a game
Miami was seven and oh this is a good
running team to get to Mike Pouncy back
Jay Cutler is going to be more of a
complementary player than a dominant Mad
Bomber and before we move on from this
topic here Peter in that 48-hour period
where Cutler was seriously considering
this and also seriously considering
staying on course with Fox the other
options for the Dolphins that we you
know I read about range from cap
to Tim Tebow I mean is that was I not I
don't think that I don't think that they
made a call to Tebow or did it let me
just say this rich if Mike Tannenbaum
considered Tim Tebow after what happened
with the New York Jets he ought to have
his head examined and I saw that
somewhere and I asked a few people there
and our I asked a few people about this
and they don't think that it's true
now I'm not saying it's categorically
not true but all I can say is Mike
Tannenbaum who you know he and gays made
this decision Mike Tannenbaum has had
his fill of Tim Tebow and I say that not
being critical of it but he realizes
that you're not winning you're not going
to the playoffs with Tim Tebow right now
well not to mention the fact he hasn't
played football in a hundred years
well I mean you know well clearly though
they feel like maybe they can't make the
playoffs with Matt Moore and then the
idea that Christian Ponder might be
brought in instead of Colin Kaepernick
is really something that's lies in the
face now well you can't say anymore Stan
this rich VRE to understand this when
they even the Kaepernick thing comes up
all right so if Colin Kaepernick had
been thought had been the guy signed by
Miami he would have come in at the
beginning anyway as a backup quarterback
okay so you have to ask yourself because
Matt Moore knows this offense he's been
there you know he played well he's just
very you know he's not durable but he
played pretty well last year in several
games but he also has been concussed so
you don't know about his future but the
big difference with Kaepernick do you
want to bring a guy in as a backup and
and and basically then take this month
to try to teach him your offense whether
it be Kaepernick or ponder because both
of those guys would have come in as a
backup quarterback and Matt Moore would
have been the starter and the reason why
you have to come in with somebody is
that you know you don't want to have
David fails one snap away from being
your quarterback on a team that
potentially could win double digits and
be a very strong playoff contender so
you've got to bring in some veteran
whoever it's going to be and I would
agree with those who would say that it
was probably going to be ponder but I
don't know that for sure
a couple more minutes here with Peter
King here on the Rich Eisen show and the
last time that we saw a quarterback
injury bring about somebody that was
brought in last moment and who
supposedly knew the offense was last
year would Sam Bradford who went into a
division with a 12 topic just like
Cutler now in New England you chatted
with Aaron Rodgers what were your
impressions with Aaron Rodgers
entering yet another season for the
Packers with so many high hopes very
happy very much at peace with himself
as happy with his physical condition as
he has been since he's entered the NFL
did a lot of yoga did a lot of
stretching work this offseason you know
rich a lot of times I go into a place
like Green Bay and I'll have a few
minutes with Rodgers and I'll always ask
really good players what did you do this
offseason to get better because who
knows what they did you know and
sometimes it's an interesting answer and
he said basically being one full year on
this diet where everything I put my body
is good and getting heavily into yoga
and getting a stretching regimen that I
think is going to help meal ask her me
as he said in his words and I quote him
exactly seven eight nine or ten more
years because that's how much longer he
wants to play hmm you also went into
Seattle too and I loved reading about
that give your two cents to those who
have yet to read your mmq be about what
you well I think the the ESPN story by
Seth wickersham you know although that
they do their best to minimize it and to
bury it it's still on their minds
Richard Sherman talked to me and I want
to say he's bitter about it but he's
just done really unhappy at this
perception that that he hates Russell
Wilson and that he has no respect for
him and all that and they told me that
the day I was at practice he said I
yelled worse things at Doug Baldwin than
I yelled at Russell Wilson so you got to
know who we are and you got to know how
we compete out there and that that could
very well be
but I I mean I look I thought last year
what Sherman did with Darrell Bevell was
flat-out wrong on the sidelines and I
just you know rich I just don't like the
fact that this is such a ridiculously
chippy team in practice during training
camp I mean Frank Clarke is borderline
out of control you know he was it was
hard to control him the day that I was
there and then I saw that later in the
week he got kicked out of practice for a
day for having another fight and I just
you know it's not this is not the
national fighting league it's a National
Football League and the Seahawks got to
settle down last one for you Peter here
in the Honda inside a report I know you
were selector Pro Football Hall of Fame
and you are just like me and everybody
else we love the speeches we love the
journey told and the journey now
completed for so many men but it's it
it's wrong half Kurt Warner out there at
10:00 after 11:00 at night how how do
you see this being fixed because right
now the Friday jacket ceremony is a lot
more concise and it's a lot more
emotional to be honest with you
differently these guys cry on Friday
night and then Saturday they tell their
speeches look rich I mean I just think
that the NFL or the Pro Football Hall of
Fame has got to get a handle on the
length of these features you know these
speeches ought to be 20 or 22 minutes
long you cannot thank every football
coach you've ever had in your life you
can't thank every person who has done
something for you in your life I'm sorry
you just can't do that
I mean it's just it's time for the for
the Hall of Fame just set a
hard-and-fast limit I think 20 or 22
minutes is plenty and although I love
and LaDainian Tomlinson speech was the
best of the lot you know that was 25
minutes and so easily you can get three
or four minutes out of that speech but
all I'm saying rich is that this is I
love watching these things because it's
really so many of them are so
inspirational but but honestly I think
it was ridiculously unfair I wasn't
there you were there but I heard there
were like four hundred people left when
Kurt Warner was been in with Spanish
speech troop and that's that's just
that's utterly preposterous it's totally
unfair to Kurt Warner you know to
basically be speaking to a studio
audience and that's it and his family I
mean it's just it's it's ridiculously
unfair and I think you know I love the
Hall of Fame but they got to do
something about this Peter thanks for
the time appreciate it before you go
asking the poll question real quick I'd
love to get his two cents on it brah hey
Peter who makes more starts this year
quarterback Jay Cutler Mike Glennon Tom
Savage Brock Osweiler what do you think
Jay Cutler easy I mean uh you know Brock
Osweiler I don't think it's starting for
the Browns and I don't think I don't
think that Tom Savage makes it through
the year I think it's going to be
deshaun Watson steam by midseason Peter
love to chat with you always will chat
down the line
certainly later on this month thanks a
lot great you you got it that's Peter
King again the mm QB check it out the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what attaches